my review for Batman Arkham City will
come out soon enough but before that we
got a review Batman Arkham Asylum so
without further ado here is my review of
the Burkman
Batman Arkham Asylum so Batman Arkham
Asylum is a Batman game that came out
for the Xbox 360 ps3 I don't think you
came out for PC but I'm not quite sure
when it was coming out everyone was like
it looks cool but it's a Batman game DC
comic games usually are not good - one
was like Batman Returns for Super
Nintendo throwing dudes into the
building glass that was rad and then it
came out and holy crap totally different
story Oh Batman is voiced by Kevin
Conroy if you don't know who that is
he's Batman from the Batman the Animated
Series it was like the definitive Batman
voice anyone who hates the whole ok the
voice I really don't have too much of a
problem with it although I will not pass
up an opportunity to talk [ __ ] good it
is a goofy ass voice sometimes though
it's like the best Batman voice is all
like gin it sounded more like bones from
Star Trek I'm just saying Jim and the
Joker is voiced by Mark Hamill who is
the Joker in the Batman the Animated
Series so it's almost like they were
like alright the voices in Batman the
Animated Series that they're great
they're iconic they work they're perfect
we're gonna have them in this game and
guess what they're just as perfect in
this game now in Batman Arkham Asylum
Batman's dropping Joker off at Arkham
Asylum you don't know what that is that
that's the nut bin it's a loony bin of
Gotham so all the crazies go and then
the Joker takes control of Arkham Asylum
and Batman now has to take them down and
it kind of has that really classic 3d
game structure which is kind of
structured off of like Metroid or
Castlevania Symphony of the Night I
think that's a little better
you had your game app then you find
ledges doors whatever places that you
can't quite go there you get an ability
that let you go there and explore them
to find another place you're like I
can't go there now and you get another
ability any kind of stacks like that
until you explore 100% of the place I
like that I like those game modes it
gives you an opportunity to get a
hundred percent of the secrets in the
game usually in games i mean you know
i'm playing Uncharted I'm like oh I miss
treasures what god forbid I still get to
go on with the game right let's just do
that I like the story I like the
gameplay I don't need to get 100% of the
secrets but in Arkham Asylum the
Riddler's hidden a bunch of secrets
around you're finding these hidden
things that are like the story of
Amadeus Arkham you find character reals
character bios audio tapes at their
therapy sessions the Riddler has one of
the coolest ones about the baby that was
awesome Arkham Asylum is the first game
and I think years that I maxed out 100%
that's crazy for me but you
no if you don't do it you're not worthy
to be the bridge man Batman Arkham
Asylum does a really good job putting
you in the role of the Batman you build
up XP and you can buy moves and
abilities one of which is you can dangle
upside down on these gargoyles then when
a guy gets under you you can just zip
line down grab them zip line back up no
one sees you do it so you use stealth
and you take out a roomful of guys by
the end this last guy is just freaking
out dude he's just shooting at nothing
it lets you prey on their fear that is
the Batman which is fun excels like sway
stealth takedowns not stealth kills how
can you have fun with no stealth kills I
understand it's Batman but I just
thought fun and self kills went together
I'm American dude but it really works
it's so fun to take these guys out and
Batman doesn't kill anyone in the game
and that is little bit rare the battle
system is really fun too does a good job
of just plopping you among like 20 guys
you have combos you can do different
moves stuff like that that's like you
know necessary in a game like this but
when a guy comes up to hit you if you
push the counter-attack button no matter
what Batman's doing he will
counter-attack that guy's leg or
whatever he tries to kick you will grab
his leg break it and then go back to
work you walk out of there like dude I
am such a badass right now
I am the brat bird I don't know why I
keep saying that like that but I do when
I first played this game it was really
close to when it came out so no one knew
about Arkham City or anything like that
so Batman and having the coolest
villains ever had like a handful of the
villains in this game so almost like
dude it's a fun ass game but I would
like to have seen this villain this
villain that villain who are in Arkham
City so it's really great game making to
be like alright we're gonna take these
villains not all the villains in Batman
just these villains and build it to be
the coolest game we can make it and have
it be that badass and save enough for
the sequel to be hopefully good you know
not using all your tricks in the first
game not burning it out that is awesome
so the voice acting is great the
characters are great the villains are
great the gameplay is badass it puts you
in the driver's seat of the Batman and
they do it flawlessly by Batman Arkham
Asylum it's like 20 bucks now so if you
don't buy it you're just missing out
you're doing yourself a huge disservice
people have told me it's a really good
mix of Nolan Batman meets comic-book
Batman I wouldn't call it Nolan Batman I
mean yeah it's really gritty but that
doesn't make a Nolan Batman I would say
it's the definitive Batman the Animated
Series extreme edition in any case it's
solid Batman lore solid Batman Canon
you're going to love it if you like
Batman so since they didn't have all the
Batman villains in Batman Arkham Asylum
what's your favorite Batman villain
whoever
maybe comment below let me know and in
any case if you like what you've seen
here and you want to see more click
right here to see more the Brackman